put it in the pocket
all right thank you uh for inviting me
to give the talk here and thanks for
staying back for the class talk so uh I
think that it's only 4 40. so I think
it's going to be short
so
um so this is a join work with uh Pavan
aduri from Iowa State University kulbi
banana from uh National University of
Singapore and myself
um
from the University of Nebraska Lincoln
so uh
a sad problem here you have a formula in
CNR form
and sad is asking uh
given this formula uh decided that there
is a truth assignment is the variable so
that if it's that way to true or false
but uh if you step back and think about
this in the Boolean uh in the in the
logic settings so what we are asking is
is the is the following said that we
have this Boolean ring and we can
interpret and or function
as uh in a natural we do and then yeah
we can also try to order these elements
0 being less than one and in this
setting you are asking uh given a
Boolean formula compute the maximum
value or interpretation of this formula
over all interpretations which is a
mapping from the variables to be
we have set
so here x is a set of variables and Pi f
is the natural extension of Pi 2x so I
will use this by notation
throughout this talk so in this in this
formulation of course apple cider style
we find only if
Max
overall interpretations Phi f is one so
of course this is the same nothing new I
added here but I think that a good thing
to view this uh the set in this form is
to actually now you can try to think of
what about other interpretation so in
particular uh here is uh one semi ring
which is a very well known similar
increase
so here is the Set uh is uh is interval
zero one real interval zero one and
let's say that we this natural order
um which is inherited from the real
numbers and then you can imagine uh and
operation as the multiplication and or
as the max
and I'll throw in this negation
interpretation which is not X is 1 minus
X
and I'll come back to that and then in
this and then you can ask this this
question of course now uh given this
formula compute maximum value of any
interpretation or odd possible
interpretation
right so you can do this calculation
here for this formula so you know you
can distribute and it becomes Max of X1
X2 into 1 minus X1 or X1 X2 1 minus X2
and uh you can see that this takes the
Optimum value at X1 equal to 0.5 x 2
equal to 1 and the value uh max value
takes is 0.25
and of course there is other
interpretations as well which is
maximizes this
but a good thing is that even in this
interpretation if it's satisfiable if
and only if it is evaluates maximum
values to one
so notice that here uh the formula was
not satisfiable but we did get something
other than zero so there's some probably
some valuable information Here
Again by by this this particular
information
so uh just going back to this negation
of course there is no negation of the
same earring so we have to kind of come
up with so you can ask what is this uh
what is the meaning of this negative so
for this work we didn't really attach
any meaning to this we uh most of the
things we assume the minimal
um a function which satisfy this minimal
condition that negation of negation of X
should be X and negation of zero is is
one
so
um but the rest of the talk I'll only
focus on X uh negation of X takes equal
to 1 minus X
and you can ask this question for any
Seminary and then there are some other
useful same earrings which people have
uh considered in various settings in
particular our interest came from the
data provenance
in the database Community where you
interpret these as confidence goes and
you know can associate some meaning to
that
but uh
we abstract those things out in this
study so but I my point is that it is
actually being you know very useful uh
in various settings and there is this
access control semi ring which also has
been
um
useful and security specifications uh
where you can think of every I in K
associated with an access control level
security
or systems with this one I have a
question yeah did they understand right
do you take interpret negation as one
minus x no so here um we in not as one
minus X so in this particular case you
can actually K minus X you know sort of
okay management yeah yeah so again
yeah so we
in the in the uh our results doesn't
really depend on what is the petition
it's it's some natural interpretation
that is also yeah yeah so that's a
that's a good question what kind of
negation makes sense I think that we we
discuss this a lot and it really depends
on where the application is coming from
um so
with this so this is the computational
problem we formulated so we call this
opt Samwell uh Optimum value for a uh
you know our every interpretation and
sum stands for semantics
so that's the problem so the problem is
let's fix some send me a ring and uh and
now the question is given a formula and
I'll assume is given a negation normal
form and compute the maximum overall
interpretation Pi effect it's a
computation problem
it's naturally extend sad
that's a Beyond set
and what we did uh so you know we didn't
know anything about so
um you know especially for we started
with the weather be simmering so we
didn't know anything about its
complexities we started investigating
what will be the complexity of this
problem
and as I mentioned it's at least NP hard
because uh you know
satisfiable if and only if this
evaluates to 1 4 37 so
so what we showed is this this
particular upper and lower bound so we
showed that over the Derby
interpretation it is at least as hard as
FP to the NP log which is the class of
problems can be solved in polynomial
time with log many queries to
satisfiability or equivalently parallel
queries to science
and we give an algorithm which is runs
in uh polynomial time with sat queries
that's the
main result so to say what we came up
and uh we could show other things too so
for other more finite cases like Access
Control this boils down to equivalent to
set so it's nothing
in terms of the complex
so what I'm going to do in the next uh
two slides or two this is one slide but
it's going to show you know so is to
show a proof uh not the entire proof but
the outline of the proof and the reason
is that it kind of interesting some of
the things seems to be more General than
just the proof itself so
um so what we showed is that okay we can
reduce the max set to up some valve and
Max side is the problem you're given a
Boolean formula in Sienna form you want
to compute the maximum set number of
satisfiable Clauses and it is known that
this is ft to the NP log
to this
so I think that one of the interesting
um
foreign
formula in CNF form
with M classes and let R be the maximum
number of satisfied Clauses over the
Clauses over the Boolean ring then any
with turbine interpretation the value is
going to be less than 1 1 by 4 pm minus
r
so it is somewhat uh independent of
anything it is just very general so I I
put confidence bounding because again
coming from the turbine interpretation
there is some meaning of confidence Etc
so it's basically saying that
or if I have a Mac side instance with r
being the maximum number of satisfiable
Clauses then you cannot get better then
it's uses some combinatorial
non-communitions
um
basic analysis of this formula
so and then once this is then the
reduction is pretty uh easy so I can
show that so what we will do is you take
a Formula F C enough form we will add
this
class for every class in the CNF F form
Formula F we will introduce
CI Union y as a new variable so you add
M new variable and also throw in the
negations of those
then we can actually show that this is
exactly 1 over 4 to the m to the other
option value or the optimum value it can
take is 1 over 4 to the m minus r but R
is the number of satisfied clouds okay
and the way we'll do that is that we can
actually give an interpretation Pi so
that Pi F star Pi F Prime is 1 over 4 to
the N minus r and because of the
confidence bounding gamma it's the best
possible because the new formula has two
M Clauses and
plus r Clauses can be size
so therefore it is a reduction because I
can actually now solve option value on F
Prime and gets the value and compute r
foreign
binary search language and search for
this in exponential space using an NP
language so we Define this Lop language
which is formula and some value and and
that's in the language if it's greater
than the value of course the main
challenge is that again these
interpretations are on zero one so
what if this value is rational or things
like you know you can still of course it
doesn't exclude such possibilities but
uh what we can claim is that actually
this Falls in this uh sequence called
fare sequence over
and two to the polynomial and the size
of the formula fatty sequences of order
n are fractions of the form a by B where
uh A and B L is n equal to n and gcd of
a b is one so it's in fact when we
started looking at it's very well
studied algorithms for fatter sequences
uh you know surprisingly somewhat
difficult even to get rank of a element
in the fairy sequence Etc
so
um I think that's kind of interesting
that that this popped up in this
particular upper bound
and of course there are other technical
challenges but
um once
we have you know the the pro the claim
that it it doesn't
the arbitrary we can actually go through
the rest of the proof without much with
some work
so I also looked at this approximation
problem uh of of you know how close you
can approximate and you can get an upper
bound which is uh 0.76
716 to the m approximation for
uh three CNN formulas then plus so we
can actually get it for any c any CNF
but then the expression will not be this
nice
and uh you can show that it's also hard
to approximate Beyond 0.845
and that's the the technical uh the
content of uh you know the results I
wanted to present and of course there
are these technical questions you know
we thought about it is it we cannot
still
uh conclude which way to go whether it
is closer to the max at or it's close to
the legs first time to because
so we don't know where it actually
and of course
um if the tasks we use the logical you
have to come up with some algorithm so
that's um
can we use sat solvers or to actually
get useful information
of course a non-technical question is to
why is this is this problems useful is
this problem make sense and our research
came from in fact the database uh
connection I mentioned we were looking
at provenance and that's how we Define
this problem Etc so it seems like there
is an increasing interest Beyond Boolean
interpretations in database in fact uh
the the next semester we have this
program
logic and algorithms in database Theory
and Ai and one of the themes is
extensions of logic to similarities
um that's it
so I think
let me go back to navigation all right
okay I have I have a suggestion what you
how you could interpret this so one this
is what's done sometimes in finite model
Theory people are also looking at finite
structures whose atoms are labeled by
elements from from some seven ring and
then what they look at is that what they
call model defining assignments so that
means an assignment to every atom and
every negated atom Alzheimer of a value
from the summary in such a way that at
most one between
sorry at least one between atom and the
negative atom is zero ah okay and then
you can ask the question maximize over
model finding assignments I see so
that's an actual negation which has been
considered in the same meaning
situations
the classical equivalence of first of
the logic going away
anything you can imagine the implication
being the junction of negation all these
things go away unless you define them so
you have to be very careful you have to
welcome negation normal form yeah so
that's what we have we realize that we
need to work with negative normal form
so all the things we have but then it
might be difficult to say it's a very
nice introduction to the
submitting semantics or first or the
logic is enough still archive paper by
Gretel and Tannen that came out of the
2016 program here I see yeah I think I
we must have seen this uh that's
yeah but I think that we'll talk about
that negation a little bit more closely
yeah
I just wanted to add so well Canon is
who gave us oh yeah that's true who
introduced us to that and and this
problem we were motivated from reverse
provenance analysis which is discussing
yeah
so
okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign